red joins us now on loan from Turner
Sports good morning reg good morning
Theodore how are you and Maidan is how
you feeling I feel good I played 12 we
had the first floor and Dayton and then
rolled over to Iowa and played four so
I'm hanging in there my friend how is it
when you have two games in one day so
you have those back-to-back games those
aren't the problem is the four game in
one day it wears you out the Thursday
that's the most difficult day of the
year personally for myself because
you're preparing for eighteen four games
and there's so many players and it's not
like you've watched all these teams all
year long you know it's almost like
you're taking a you know a quiz test but
you rely on your notes your reading your
prep and you get a chance to watch the
practices and talk to the coaches and
the players and then at the end of the
day basketball is basketball and you're
talking about X's and O's and strategy
and I'm with a great crew Dan Bonner has
been doing this for 34 years college
basketball so I lean on him for a little
bit but we have great chemistry and
Kevin Harlan Kevin Harlan Dana Jacobson
is award-winning Emmy sideline reporter
so we have a great crew best team you've
seen so far best team I will say this
and again they were in our section I
think it's gonna come down to defense
and you've got to have great guard play
and cassius winston for Michigan State
and Xavier Simpson they don't get a lot
of fun even though Cassius Winston was
Big Ten Player of the Year obviously and
rightfully so much of the attention has
been Duke and John Moran and and that I
get it but these two players what they
do you've got to have great guard play
at this time of year they control pace
they control tempo and both makes big
shots and they understand tournament
basketball because it both have been
deep in the tournament I wouldn't say
they're the best
I've seen but in terms of team success
what caches Winston did in our game
especially when they started to make a
run on them and he went on a 900 run
personally himself Cassius Winston has
looked fantastic for Michigan State you
ever been yelled at like is oded to his
freshmen yeah yes and you take it you
understand that it's coming from love
Larry Brown was he's from that tree and
it's called coaching people I didn't
have a problem with it and apparently if
you read some of the comments you know
from former players that's what Coach
Izzo is I know people don't like it but
what about you know Rick Barnes shoving
his flare out of the way I mean it's
that's what these coaches do I get it
you know people think there's other ways
of coaching too you know some coaches
aren't as demonstrative on the sidelines
but coach Izzo is he's not going to let
things slip through the cracks and he's
looking at the bigger picture and if
Aaron Henry is missing defensive
assignments which he was he's looking at
the big picture if we continue to move
on in this tournament we cannot have
this slippage and he's not going to let
their freshmen off the hook you've got
to always look at the bigger picture
when you're these coaches if Duke could
not won yesterday what would we be in
Washington well first of all let me just
say this as I waves there's no question
the number one pick we've talked about
that but he did not want any he didn't
want any business of that free throw on
that and why any part of that free throw
and I will also say this taco will be a
EA player because of his size he had
great hands I think he will be I'm not
saying he's going to be JoEllen bead but
he definitely be play well on a team
really
cuz of his thighs I think he will okay I
really do for him to play that late in
the game because I just thought RJ
Barrett and Zion was just gonna attack
him which they did at times but he held
his own and if he had not found out they
do not get that offensive rebound at the
end and they end up winning that ball
game to me
you see if they blew that game that was
theirs to win and young players don't
know time and score if you remember they
had that two-on-one break and they do it
they didn't alley-oop when they were up
to I probably would have pulled it out
and ran timeout there was like under a
minute left
you got a no time in score the two
points weren't as important I know you
had a two-on-one but the guy missed the
alley you and they came back down and
scored and tied the ballgame up you got
a no time and score and a lot of young
college players they forget about that
Zion is the first player to score at
least 55 points and shoot at least 60%
from the floor through the first two
games of the NC double-a tournament
since 1987 Billy Donovan and you okay so
is Billy Donovan Billy Donovan wasn't
shooting lamps that is true well that's
an amazing stat I had no idea thank you
for enlightening me thats a feel letter
would feel no better today know about my
career did you have did you know
anything about Venice Denbo when you
absolutely nothing
[Music]
okay and you're welcome Finnish nimble
because I got you paid and drafted by
the Detroit Pistons so you're welcome
you're welcome who say there's a there's
always you know - one or two of these
guys every tournament not the Jama rant
you know had a needed a coming-out party
but Harold arsenault like Bryce Drew
there's always its you know they're just
le I'm Ally Farrokh Minesh I think was
his name at Northern Iowa you just had
these guys and you go I don't know if
they ever play again but we don't have
that guy in this tournament do we we did
a guy a player off of fairleigh
dickenson in the first floor by the name
of Dylan Windler a 6-8 kid I believe
he's actually from Indiana that knew
good zoomed but he was our game and they
found a way to win yeah you know Darnell
edge was a star but his next game versus
I believe it was Maryland he went for 35
I know I know he was bombed remember
that yeah remember that name because he
will be in the NBA
Dylan Windler wait you've got a lot of
guys going to the NBA here reg I got
taco Falls taco will be in the NBA go
fall make it seem like it's okay where
are you going I'm going to I'm going to
taco Falls oh it's really pretty it's
like a state park oh you got to go - to
Zion you got to go to taco Falls you
know all these great places yeah I just
think because of his size number one
great hands and he will learn his
agility is not quite there because he at
times he was very passive especially
when they were attacking him but he'll
learn that that's something that can be
learned I just think he's going to be a
serviceable NBA player and that it won't
be great but he'll be serviceable look
hold on yeah I love okay it
Bauval can make it taco can make it
right I think so
yeah okay yeah I think so by the way
James Harden went for 61 on Friday yes
do we give him the MVP if they finished
number three and the injuries through
all the injuries and what he has done is
he the MVP or are we still on Jana I
would give it to horse record it I would
give it to harden
I couldn't fault you and I wouldn't be
upset if you want it but it's something
about Yanis and Milwaukee small-market
three Norman I did our coach Budenholzer
they weren't expected to you know
contend in these now they have the best
record in the NBA yeah I can't fall
either one this is this may be the
closest MVP race that we've ever had but
but we we don't even blink anymore when
harden goes for 50 I know it's when I
thought when I saw the highlights and
then he was like a 30 no run day in the
game right they were down like big
within the last two minutes he went on a
thirty no run and pretty much like still
the game with four threes it was like
ridiculous if anybody's gonna go after
Kobe's 81 it'll it'll be Harden I know
Devin Booker got 70 but that was sort of
a playground game and clay doesn't
create enough shots on his own hardens
got the ball doesn't need your help
gets the line great three-point shooter
and you know he's got volume you know
he's got the green light to shoot as
many as he wants and he's putting up you
know 20 to 25 three-pointers one night
and he's gonna make like 18 one of these
days and then all of a sudden you had
some free throws and presto change-o you
know he's gonna be knocking on the door
I know I agree I agree
harden came go for Kobe I believe I
still believe
curry can do that too just for the
simple fact of everything you mentioned
the only thing that curry will not do as
much as hardness get to the free-throw
line but in terms of you know he can
make 10 to 15 threes a game let's say he
goes to the line you know 7 to 12 times
I mean I could see it but certainly I
would put harden in that 80 point
discussion at some point yeah what do
you have you got Gonzaga and Texas Tech
Florida State Florida State if the Rema
actually it's almost a rematch of last
year's regional when Gonzaga won against
Florida State Florida State lon and
Michigan though they I believe they went
against Texas A&M last year this time
it's Texas Tech so we got a great
regional out here agains a guy can you
know they were number one last year got
knocked off they look great thus far in
this tournament Michigan their defense
they to me they've got the best defense
left in the tournament and a team that
went deep went to the Final Four last
year so they have experience there well
coach with Coach beeline so we have a
great matchup in Anaheim yeah I think
first team does 62 and the Michigan
Texas Tech game will win yeah and I
really like Florida State a lot I just
like though I know they're they're good
team men
that's but I want to a Cinderella story
we don't have a Cinderella story this
year yeah we you and I we like
Cinderella but I guarantee you the
bosses you know bread you can sell
Cinderella to the Elite Eight would you
you know what they want they want what
you had last night in that UCF do game
yeah you want you see up to take them
all the way to the end and then lose
keep eyeballs on it
on the television but they want their
bigger teams to move on it would be
great to have a Liberty a Wofford UCF in
the Final Four last year we had all over
Chicago it'd be great but it doesn't
bring I mean it's a good story but they
they're thinking about switching
for bid right they sell the Cinderella
story but do they really want the
Cinderella story now you were in Sinhala
you were in San Antonio with this last
year but you're not going to be in
Minneapolis with us this year I am NOT
no I wish you know my man's name G oh
yeah could not you won scholarship you
were so I knew that when he challenged
you I think he's he was a guarded Texas
San Antonio and and he had a game-winner
earlier this year as some people pointed
out and I just remember when he started
tugging on Superman's cape and I went
all don't do this cuz soon as you hit
your first three and then you started
talking and then he was done he was and
then we brought out Patrick Ewing we're
going one-on-one with Patrick Ewing
there the show must go on without me I
know I'm gonna miss you I don't miss you
guys all right so Thursday night we'll
be watching and safe travels good to
catch up with you again reg I appreciate
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller he'll be
on the call with Kevin Harlan Dana
Jacobson Dan Bonner for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]